لكن قال لي ماذا هذا الحديث الغربي عن
تسلحي روسيا بالقمح كم الغاز الاجابه فيما
فعلته موسكو في المناطق التي تقع تحت
سيطرتها عمليات تهريب معقده لمقامه لسرقته
والعهده هنا على فاينل شيل تايمز وربما
لهذا السبب ضمت روسيا مؤخرا ازارو ضمن
اربع مناطق الاقليم يعتبر احد اكبر مناطق
انتاج الحبوب في العالم وفيه اكمل مخازن
الحبوب في اوكرانيا
اوكرانيه
للحبوب في الاراضي الاوكرانيه الشركه
يديرها رجال اعمال
الاساسي واضحه شراء القمح من المزارعين
روايه يا توته تتقارب بعض الشيء مع روايه
مصدر عسكري روسي شاحنات عسكريه تتكفل
بمهمه نقل القمح الاوكراني برا من ذا
بروسيا الى موانئ شبه جزيره القرم
لتحضيرها للتصدير على اساس منتجات الروسيه
اما في المرحله الثالثه تشحن الحبوب عبر
موانئ افيدوسيا وسيدسبول بالقرمه او ميناء
بلادي كافكاز بواسطه سفن روسيه وسوريه قبل
ان تتوجهها الى مشترين في تركيا او تتوجه
الى ميناء طرطوس السوري للتموين قبل
ارسالها الى دول اخرى مثل لبنان